antes eu estou que nem pelé na caminhada
transmil palestras mas senti uma alegria
grande estar aqui hoje com vocês e ontem
enquanto eu pensava na minha fala eu
achei que seria interessante dividir com
vocês uma idéia que é uma idéia que eu
trabalho muito com os grupos de jovens
pelos quais eu faço coaching normalmente
chama esses jovens e diga sim em algum
momento pra eles para que eles façam
exercício lembrem de quando eles eram
mais jovens com 10 nós já 11 anos
retornem às suas casas
aquela casa da infância onde a gente
brincava onde o avô ia onde tinha um
vizinho amigos primos e lá ele tem te
encontrar a criança que ele foi um dia
e aí ele desapareceu um diálogo
imaginário da criança seria assim
iniciado pela primeira pergunta você
olhando pra mim tá feliz com que você
virou no futuro
esse é um exercício de coaching
interessante porque as pessoas começam a
voltar à sua infância ea lembrar das
primeiras crenças das primeiras idéias
os princípios aprendidos com pai mãe avó
as primeiras interações com primos
amigos colegas escola primeiros
professores e essa imagem que eu trouxe
pra vocês aqui é uma imagem que a minha
bastante
levante porque enxergo muito nela na
casa do meu avô tinha uma onda depósito
ao lado da casa dele que tinha
exatamente essa com formação era um
depósito velho e tinha alguns vidros
quebrados
isso em santo andré há 40 anos atrás e
eu me enxerga naquele ano aquele menino
que está ali porque eu me vejo nele e na
verdade eu tinha um pouco esse mesmo
olhar esta mesma
nesse mesmo olhar curioso de acompanhar
quem passava pela rua e de imaginar as
histórias que aquelas pessoas tinham
então olhando para as pessoas imaginavam
que elas faziam que trabalha elas tinham
quantos filhos tinham serão felizes não
eram felizes
obviamente que isso é uma brincadeira de
um menino tímido introvertido
enquanto a maioria dos meninos da minha
idade
jogavam bola no campinho também jogava
eu já tinha preocupações como por
exemplo criar uma revista infantil e não
só criar revista escrever desenhar mas
vender a revista então já tinha leão um
espírito artístico e já tinha também o
espírito empreendedor e olhava o mundo
com um olhar do tipo eu quero fazer
alguma coisa no futuro eu não sei o que
será
mas eu quero fazer alguma coisa no
futuro em que trabalho pra mim
represente uma causa e eu tinha já
embora ainda não conseguisse formular
essa idéia uma visão muito parecida com
a que os gregos chamam de aretê tem a
ver com propósito a idéia de que a vida
vale a pena ser vivida
se eu tiver um propósito
eu não sabia exatamente qual era o meu
propósito é óbvio aos 12 anos 11 anos a
gente não sabe mas eu sabia que isso
tinha a ver com o usar a ferramenta da
linguagem usar a minha capacidade de
comunicar para mobilizar pessoas para
coisas legais
e aí também já tinha uma certa queda por
ler e estudar histórias de líderes eu
lembro bem que eu li a história de
monteiro lobato e achei fantástico que
ele era mais do que um escritor um
empreendedor
eu li a história do santos dumont e
fiquei cativado pela capacidade que ele
teve de foco de concentração e de
inventar algo tão relevante e eu também
te interesse pelas histórias das pessoas
comuns do meu bairro
aquele indivíduo que você vê como o
empresário mais bem sucedido do teu
bairro e você imagina como é que esse
sujeito chegou lá
claro que essa visão
ela não vem de graça e ela está dentro
da gente e é óbvio que essa visão vai
determinar o que a gente vai fazer na
vida né
obviamente eu podia ser um advogado um
médico que é outra coisa eu escolhi ser
jornalista
voltando então a idéia da linguagem da
informação para fazer justiça eu
imaginava quem informação poderia
contribuir para termos pessoas melhores
e educadas mais informadas mais
transformadores eu fiz jornalismo ea
minha trajetória no jornalismo foi muito
curta cinco anos
e aí eu saí do jornalismo já um pouco
cansado daquela rotina e decidi abrir a
minha empresa e ao abrir a minha empresa
o foco da minha empresa foi ajudar a
desenvolver um negócio que nos anos 90
estava crescendo no brasil chamado
terceiro setor
porque a gente sabia o que era eu tinha
estudado um pouco tinha ido nos estados
unidos feito um curso na jonas lopes
tinha voltado cheio de idéias e pensei
este negócio é legal porque é legal
porque ele vai me dar a oportunidade de
conviver com líderes legais líderes
virtuosos que colocam a sua capacidade
de ajudar outra cima de tudo isso era o
que eu queria um trabalho com a causa
o com causes e aí foi interessante
porque aconteceu exatamente isso
ao longo da minha vida eu convivi com
vários líderes e dias centenas de
líderes e pessoas como ela então
nogueira que criou doutores da alegria
ea primeira vez que eu entrei com ele no
hospital pra ver como ele fazia trabalho
dele ea seriedade com que ele fazia o
trabalho dele para crianças em uti
pediátrica
eu tive a exata noção de com pequena eu
era dada a grandeza o altruísmo em
tereza a generosidade com que aquele
sujeito se dedicava e mais do que isso a
sua capacidade de reunir um grupo de
outros jovens e treiná lo e capacitá los
para fazer um trabalho com aquele nível
de excelência para sabotar o narizinho
the palace para o hospital cantar para a
criança tinha técnica envolvida tem
estratégia envolvida mas também a vida
me colocou lado do treze da aids e mais
uma vez eu tive a noção da minha pequena
mesa do brasileiro
e aí o dia mesmo assim achei
interessante é que consegue mobilizar
dezenas
de 50 mil com vontades e é igual a
maneira como ela coordenava as 750 mil
voluntários trabalhando para levar
flores o cazetta diz ou aquela forma de
ano tendo uma bíblia para vocês e tentou
13 anos teve um papel fundamental e
infantil no brasil mas também a vida me
colocou em contato com esse sujeito é
que algumas pessoas eu vejo que é uma
platéia jovem duas pessoas não saberão
quem é pertinho no final dos anos 80
criou a primeira campanha brasileira
contra a fome ea miséria e também mais
uma vez de justiça da sua compaixão da
simplicidade ele fez esse movimento
acontecer no brasil
[Música]
idéias ea intenção de fazer acontecer
lembro bem foram montados vários comitês
na rua da minha casa tinha um a gente
levava os alimentos
aquele comitê mandava pra outro comitê
maior que depois mandava para os lugares
de destino de onde havia necessidade
e eu me encantei com a maneira como ele
montou aquela estrutura com simplicidade
mas com o incrível efetividade
pois bem eu falei só de virtudes aqui
mas aí a vida também nos coloca na final
estamos lidando com seres humanos e
seres humanos são compostos de virtudes
e vícios e também no terceiro setor e
comecei a observar uma série de vícios
como por exemplo vícios deslocados que
não deveriam estar ali mas a vaidade
havia uma certa vaidade de grupos de
vamos salvar o mundo mas eu quero a
minha assinatura em baixo como o
primeiro que salvou o mundo
e algumas coisas começaram me falta de
humildade de aprender
muitos achavam já sabiam de tudo e um
dos meus trabalhos era justamente ajudar
a que as organizações tivessem uma
gestão melhor para que os resultados
fossem melhores
aí depois de 12 anos trabalhando com
esse tema eu naturalmente saltei para
investimento social privado passei a
ajudar empresas a montar institutos e
fundações e naturalmente é um caminho
natural
fui para o campo da responsabilidade
social e da sustentabilidade novos
desafios novos em reais mas um velho
desejo voltou até a convergir interesses
e aí eu já tinha experiência de ter
trabalhado no setor não o criativo que
havia portanto menos foco hilux levar
essa idéia as empresas e fazer muitas
empresas também têm se de um modo
excelente já que as empresas impactam
muito a nossa vida tanto do ponto de
vista ambiental a social no sentido da
primeira vez profissionalmente falando
num quadrado que eu mesmo tinha criado
também e aquilo me deixou extremamente
uma empresa trabalhando de reunir esses
15 profissionais e disse só faz sentido
eu trabalhar com sustentabilidade
empresarial e sustentabilidade
empresarial for isso daqui um novo modo
de pensar e fazer negócios que reúne a
dica integridade e responsabilidade
transparência respeito ao outro e
respeito ao meio ambiente
essa é uma definição muito particular
muito pessoal que o uso dos meus
clientes para mostrar o que eu entendo
que seja hoje sustentabilidade para uma
empresa baseada em uma idéia de origem
deste inglês elton um dos grandes atores
desse movimento no mundo mas ele olhava
pra e se dizia e fazer a seguinte
pergunta pois meus consultores é
possível fazer isso daqui acontecer
empresas sendo um líder convencional e
aí as respostas não eram muito
animadoras
chegamos à conclusão depois de uma longa
pesquisa com clientes que este roteiro
aqui ele acontecer no tipo de líder
um outro perfil de liderança mas se esse
negócio é tão importante
se essa variável liderança tão
importante eu me meti numa aventura de
tentar entender como pensam agem tomam
decisões em que valores acreditam
líderes capazes de operar esta lógica
daí nasceu o primeiro livro um segundo
livro um movimento chamado plataforma de
liderança sustentável esse movimento já
vai para o seu sexto ano já inclui 75
líderes empresariais que vieram comigo
para contar as suas histórias de como
eles estão fazendo a transformação para
a sustentabilidade nas suas empresas
e aí eu fui descobrindo que sim era
possível e é possível e é desejável
conciliar o interesse e virtude
e aqui eu queria fazer uma breve
definição do que eu acho que seja
virtude
eu apresentei uma série de palavras ali
são virtudes virtude pra mim e eu acho
que vocês vão concordar comigo é como se
fosse carregar o poder do melhor que a
humanidade tem dentro de cada um de nós
e deixar que esse poder haja nas nossas
atitudes nas nossas práticas naquilo que
fazemos no dia a dia e isso pra minha
virtude e aí eu comecei a conviver com
líderes empresariais que tinham essas
virtudes porque até então quando eu
trabalhava no terceiro setor e eu
contava as histórias como essas
histórias que acabei de cantar aqui cada
uma delas daria um tédio inteiro mas eu
contava as histórias e todo mundo ficava
embevecido olhando pra mim
invariavelmente escorriam uma ou duas
lágrimas furtivas e diziam ah eu queria
ser como você eu queria trabalhar com
essas pessoas
eu queria trabalhar para o bem eu queria
construir um mundo melhor
ok porque a gente não pode fazer isso no
mundo empresarial
quando você fala do mundo empresarial a
quase sempre invariavelmente a reação
das pessoas é uma reação negativa aquele
líder daquela empresa aquilo de estranho
meio ambiente é aquela empresa trata mal
funcionário invariavelmente no
imaginário coletivo empresa e líder
empresarial está no campo dos vilões
aí eu quis mostrar que a gente pode
trabalhar com líderes que têm algumas
características que eu considero que
sejam características relevantes de um
líder que pensa e age de um modo mais
sustentável a primeira delas é acreditar
e praticar de verdade alguns valores que
sustenta as que dão sustentação a
sustenta
idade como ética transparência
diversidade e respeito ao outro e
respeito ao meio ambiente
aí alguém vai olhar e vai dizer puxa mas
nada mais óbvio não deveria ser assim
com todo mundo
sim mas parece haver algo estranho o
mecanismo estranho
mergulhado no fundo do subconsciente das
pessoas que trabalham em empresas que
elas mudam o jeito de pensar e de fazer
conforme empresa onde elas estão
trabalhando
elas deixam de lado os seus valores e
passa a operar com os valores daquela
empresa líder sustentável para mim
alguém que acredite prática no dia a dia
dos negócios os valores que pratica fora
do negócio aqui teria um milhão de
histórias para contar sobre ética
diversidade o tempo não vai permitir
infelizmente líderes sustentáveis para
mim são pessoas que têm coragem de tomar
determinadas atitudes que às vezes vão
contra a maré tem a capacidade de manter
aquilo que dizem para as pessoas nas
suas acções e têm resiliência capacidade
de enfrentar todas as resistências e os
obstáculos e não desistir
são líderes que têm a capacidade de
criar sinergia entre pessoas idéias e
recursos em torno das suas idéias de
sustentabilidade e sempre com paixão é
uma palavra um pouco fora de moda essa
ou quase sempre colocada num contexto
romântico quando eu digo paixão aqui eu
digo sangue nos olhos verdade
autenticidade sinceridade de fazer
aquilo no dia a dia porque acredita de
fazer aquilo no dia a dia porque acha
importante porque tem convicção de fazer
até porque sustentabilidade
muitas empresas adotam por conveniência
e não por convicção
são empresas que cujos líderes enxergam
os grandes temas os grandes impactos
colocam isso no centro do negócio
desenvolvem novos produtos processos e
serviços e inovam para melhorar a vida
de cada um de nós aliás também dariam
ted falar sobre novas sobre inovações
para a sustentabilidade que tem ocorrido
nos últimos dois anos e provavelmente
muitos de vocês nem sabem que estão
sendo desenvolvidas hoje líderes
sustentáveis têm uma visão sistêmica e
principalmente uma noção de
interdependência o que eu quero dizer
com isso ao invés de enxergar a árvore
enxergam uma floresta e conseguem
enxergar e ver todas as relações entre
as atividades da empresa os seus
impactos e os públicos com os quais ela
se relaciona as empresas para as quais o
lixo e esse talvez seja um emblema do
nosso da nossa sociedade
o lixo ele não é um problema que se
resolve quando a gente põe o saco de
lixo na porta de casa
esse lixo vai voltar pra gente de alguma
maneira final devemos do mundo
interdependente e a solução para o lixo
não é aumentar aterro
a solução para o lixo a diminuir lixo
para diminuir o lixo precisa ter visão
sistêmica eu preciso enxergar o problema
de um modo mais complexo porque a
realidade é complexa
líderes sustentáveis são jardineiros
mais do que comandantes militares
eles preparam as condições nas suas
empresas para fazer florescer novos
líderes sustentáveis líderes que
entregam resultados e valores
eu acho que eu tenho uma coisa em comum
com esses caras e acho que essa imagem
eu gosto de fotografia
ela reflete muito aquilo que eu acho que
eu tenho em comum com eles e eu não
posso falar dessa imagem sem voltar
aquela primeira imagem daquela criança
olhando pela fresta de um vidro quebrado
o mundo acontecendo à sua volta
aquela criança que se transformou num
consultor de sustentabilidade tem em
comum com os líderes que admira a mesma
ideia o mesmo desejo de tornar esse
mundo um lugar melhor para se viver e
fazer da vida algo que vale a pena ser
vivida
como é que eu tenha feito isso
eu tenho ouvido neste momento é um
projeto muito legal que é transformar
meninos de baixa renda da base da
pirâmide em jovens líderes sustentáveis
em pouco mais de seis meses
o projeto agente formoso 8 mil jovens de
baixa renda ea maioria desses jovens de
baixa renda
essa entrar no mercado de trabalho ea
primeira pesquisa dos empregadores
mostra o seguinte esses meninos em
relação à média dos meninos não
treinados neste programa tem mais
atitude mas altruísmo mais espírito
colaborativo melhor visão sistêmica e
valores mais acentuados
ou seja eles tomam decisões baseadas em
valores é nisso que acredita e essa
mensagem que eu queria deixar para vocês
hoje
[Aplausos]